multitudes de activistas a favor y en
contra del aborto se congregaron frente
a la corte suprema de eeuu este martes
respondiendo a un borrador de opinión
filtrado anularía el histórico fallo roe
versus vuelta
cuanto más analices la embriología más
te darás cuenta de que no son solo
algunas células son seres humanos
cuando me falló el control de la
natalidad de mi esposo y yo tomamos la
decisión de tener un aborto legal y me
horroriza que esta decisión les sea
arrebatada a mis nietos y nietas horas
hablando fuera de la corte el líder de
la mayoría del senador chuck schumer
dijo que la decisión sería una
abominación y prometió una votación en
el senado para garantizar el acceso al
aborto con una votación sobre esta
legislación ya no es un ejercicio
abstracto esto es tan urgente y real
como parecía en el río de kirch por su
parte la corte suprema emitió un
comunicado confirmando la autenticidad
del documento predijo que no
representaba una posición final el
presidente del tribunal supremo john
roberts dijo que la publicación era una
traición pero que no detendrá las
discusiones mitch mcconnell el líder de
la minoría de la cámara alta- condenó la
filtración y acusó a los liberales de
querer intimidar a la corté coche la
corte debe desconectarse del ruido de la
mala fe y sentirse completamente libre
para hacer su trabajo
el presidente de eeuu yo bailé en
criticó el borrador
en primer lugar acabo de recibir una
llamada diciendo que se ha anunciado que
es un borrador real pero aún no
representa quien votará por él espero
que no haya suficientes votos
la idea que me preocupa mucho es que
después de 50 años vamos a decir que una
mujer no tiene derecho a elegir según
los límites de la decisión de la corte
suprema-
y advirtió que otros derechos incluido
el matrimonio entre personas del mismo
sexo y el control de la natalidad sigue
adelante